hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Kraven Manor we're
now at a piece of a puzzle we need to
figure out how to do it which means that
we need to put two globes in the place
where I okay that was wrong sorry
nyeh so anyway what what you need to do
is you need to read these people's minds
and tell them that they are dumb anyway
so what I did wrong there's actually I
was trying to drop it and I accidentally
put it I'm not stupid
Jaqueline wearing blue is honest oh
really what is blue
oh no blank blues a liar that means
you're a liar the globe belongs in the
rightmost frame maybe you're telling the
truth third frame from the left no
that's wrong so you're wrong let's see
framing the leftmost side purple telling
the truth frame on the leftmost side huh
hey somebody's a liar yes I think I
think it's wait
and I remember whose was whose house I
supposed to know whose is whose --is
wait a minute I write this entry with
trembling bleeding hands a trap was
sprung as it plates a globe in the frame
I must have done something wrong I am
sure this globe is linked to the door
but it would be reckless to randomly try
as I bound my wounds I notice a book
near the portraits well okay if you say
so
Rand Green is a liar that's yellow so
Green is a liar but you're a liar so
greens not a liar right most frame blue
is honest just because you're a liar
doesn't mean that you don't get it
I don't know I don't know who's this
Holmes hey did it I totally guessed and
I won oh yeah
oh you oh you lovely people there's a
saw something tells me that you guys
hanging doesn't really have an effect on
you look like you're in pain oh this
book is open to an illustration of sake
your children about to look under his
bed in the devil waiting for him
underneath oh oh wait a minute Hey look
leave are
we broke off it did I got it oh yes I
remember you
lovely lovelies Oh
oh yeah okay
they stole the souls and they put them
in the herbs and then they exploded
everywhere everybody had a fun time
hey everybody Wang Qiang okay so I gotta
go back and put this in the dumbwaiter
oh you're not looking so good anymore
and then send it on its way
cuz I'm totally blocked off yes yes yes
I did it I did it I'm doing it on the
best I'm the best there ever was maybe
not the best there ever was
but to you you're the best that ever
wants to me okay I'll just finish the
game no no come on now don't be in silly
Billy
I don't want to play I want to get this
done and then go on my way to the secret
the secret whoa the secret
very good I just want to make sure
there's all the chest it's gone hmm
wow that was interesting but oh good I
get to go the basement again
my favorite here we go hello hello you
just screwed up everything
wait oh wait is he doing
what is knocking around over there
okay okay I'm not going through there
wait which way was the way that went to
the way which way was the way that led
to where I'm supposed to go there's
another way to go over here well we I
got Turner we can turn around all over
the place there's another way to go over
here but what was that thing over there
Jacqueline and George Craven were found
dead in their home and doubtful pass
police suspect the incident to be a
murder-suicide yay that's cheerful stuff
going on here okay so this wasn't a way
to go to the other baby one's been
yeah did I just step in blood I want to
know if I just stepped in blood oh yeah
I remember you stop stopping randomly
makes me think my game is Croatian so
hello a barely legible note including
the words lever bottles in well and a
rough musical scale several combinations
of the numbers 1 2 & 3 & 4 are crossed
out never bought as well leather bottles
well lever bottles well never lever
bottles well so yeah lever bottles well
mm-hmm King Bing bong Bing bong I think
I remember this but I don't remember all
right
what okay I see this isn't quite what I
remember last time but so those the see
that was like a red bottle was the ding
so why am i coughing oh do I have it let
me get him out of time what is this do
okay so that was the one from before so
that means this
oh no no no those run oh god I'm about
to die hey oh I got in this one huh oh
no gimme gimme gimme me huh I'm the best
stop killing me please I'll just be on
my way
yeah bye oh hey you handsome devil you
you got creepy eyes I carefully explain
to each of them that this is not death
they will still live more fully than
before
yet they wail and call me a monster they
fail to appreciate their contribution to
science the brilliancy of alchemical
elemental science yeah sure oh hello
thank you for closing the door I'm very
rude I don't do it myself yes I remember
you I remember this book okay you just
sparks I remember you I really want to
get to see what the secret is okay sorry
I'll be okay I really want to know what
the secret is
I want the secret a secret now shattered
glass or team to a pest from within orb
can hold a soul for several seconds of
statues for years and the ritual is held
on crap and Manor itself limbo may mean
everlasting life don't know if that
would be a good thing considering the
options thank you but I didn't want to
leave anyway blood-stained Brown with
blood sorry I read that wrong again my
brain is not working gas therapy using
nitrous oxide
the fun laughing yes here I think I hear
the whales of the Damned I finally
reached a white room filled with glass
walls it feels cold and dry within the
smell and smells a blood metal unlike
the rest of the manor there is no
mistaking this place for a home
its purpose is clear people died here or
did they just find new life
Arden okay
handbook of physiology phrenology and
fizzies good anomie all right those are
very interesting subjects where do I go
for me by Traverse back up oh boy
hello my hands a good thing I don't
remember that
did that happen before oh oh oh oh yeah
I remember now
I need your bread
I reckon I gotta break
as some dramatic ass music come on you
masty bastard I'm gonna run really quick
Oh always that side I thought it was the
other side I'm going thank you let's
take a different way stop it with that
here we go I got
I got
give me like what are we oh yeah wait do
I do this George Monroe well here we go
then I don't know what I did differently
from last time other than stand directly
across from it now everything is on fire
run run the roof the roof the roof is on
fire Oh God that is terrifying
okay so I need to go the long way around
I'm guessing yes I don't need that I
don't think I need anything
get out yeah I was doing that I'll do
that thing
mean to do what did that oh okay
excuse me I'll just be on my way I'm
level exam
lovely lovely say what
Oh order and all that y'all like your
order don't you mr. Craven again very
dramatic very dramatic music
okay that's like oh hi what are you
doing why are you no I said no no no
once again with the bad tension oh yeah
we're on fire here too good I wonder
blazing Inferno was going to live okay
all right
I remember this beware like over there
I'm an idiot is right in front of me
okay we this is normal
all right oh good
I remember this is so crazy let's just
assume is the first time I've gone up
this cuz I'm not an idiot I swear huh oh
god oh god you guys haven't seen
anything you guys don't have not seen
how many times that I feel that this
right you guys weren't watching before
right right
I'm very smart actually whoa bump and oh
hello goodbye hello goodbye
hello good boy okay so now I need to do
a thing
hello I'm sorry I don't want to do that
I'm gonna go I have a package that I
need to pick up that I'm gonna get whoa
dodging your poor Bo explosions do I
have it
one way my way to go
where to go put it out where we go Pat
it ready right away
what
without [ __ ] [ __ ]
but that back
mate
but back that back
right there right here right away
when I go
any [ __ ] you couldn't show okay where
did it go I saw it in there some
[ __ ] right there okay take two this
time don't screw me over how about you
do to that game maybe he blew it up with
his big words miss me this time there it
is okay I got it now
okay
there we go elevator whoa okay what is
this do
well alright then we get to escape the
chaos apparently where we going and why
are we going there whoa wait a minute no
way Oh we're gonna get the new stuff yes
yes yes yes indeed
for me whoa that looks awesome
Wow that all looks so cool whoa whoa
we're moving oh that's cool
oh it's cool what is that oh look at
that so many rooms it's the whole house
moving its cube it's the movie cube
oh it's cube that's awesome oh it's cool
what's so cool that's kind of creepy all
this shots so cool hey wait alright I'm
gonna finish this up in the next episode
cuz I'm all out of time for this one be
doing it is reticule I can't wait to see
what's coming up so thank you again
everybody for watching check the
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you hello
everybody my name is Marvin we're right
back in the action we're in the new area
and if you don't know what I was saying
before about how this is cube there's a
movie cube where it's a bunch of rooms
and they move
in accordance with each other and if you
can't tell that's what's happening right
now it's kind of like you know in Portal
2 all the rooms they moved around it's
like that but here and it's awesome
they've really made it seem like we're
moving we are [ __ ] it Iowa I'm gonna
be very meticulous about this the last
page from a journal signed by Wayne
Cooley they cannot find me here I can
still hear their claws on the tiles
above but they cannot find me here the
elevator went off its tracks on the way
down I don't have anywhere else to go
but forward okay so who is Wayne Milka
Luke and why are those Gurney's filled
with blood and/or wine they could be
wine there could be a big party in cake
down here we're not probably the not
option that's why what it is okay so I
don't think there's anything else that
I'm missing besides those weird
bloodstains statues in there everything
else seems broken and dusty who built
this place and how awesome were they oh
so cool oh so cool
ah so cool oh look at that girl itself
y'all I don't care if you guys don't
think it's as cool as I think it is
illegal there better be a good finish to
this because if this just turns out that
I walk into a place and it's like oh I
go home now I'm gonna be very upset
oh don't no don't do that thing that
you're doing I want there to be other
cool stuff they had knew about it I
cannot believe that they wouldn't have
added cool stuff to this game
come on
please be cool I'm kind of getting a bad
feeling oh there's not cool stuff coming
wanna see it and why
I was so badly
[ __ ] you
what the [ __ ] was that was some [ __ ]
over here leading me up to think this is
the coolest thing I've ever seen working
towards that I just could be anywhere I
don't die by some Bulls did wouldn't it
was added to the game
what new is there oh come on you Jane
just got interesting I I wanted to see
you the house if on the back of it the
man behind the curtain wanna see more oh
come on not saying the game was bad the
sonocent game was great that's why I
wanted so much more and that's why I was
so disappointing to see it is end like
that
I mean Oh fine I get to live this is
fantastic you know the other ending was
cool to where I got turned into a bronze
Angie you can see that in my old
playthrough of it but God
into the coolest part of the game and
then just rip it away from me like that
I went into this mansion because I was
curious I just leave anyway so that was
Kraven Manor obviously this isn't the
fourth part this is just a tacked on
ending to the third part where it all
goes horribly wrong either way it's
still a great game it's incredibly well
made but oh there was so much more there
and I was thoroughly expecting there to
be a lot more content considering this
was you know on Steam now I can't even
remember if it cost money I thought it
did
I brought should probably go check just
make sure Han okay anyway it is 10 bucks
on Steam but I can't remember if it cost
money before I thought it was a free
game but I may have been totally wrong I
want to I'm not judging it based on how
much it cost
anyway I'm judging a base on how I feel
which is compromised right now because I
was just getting into it and I was told
there was so much more than just an
addition of an attic in the ending that
makes you not die and frankly the ending
that makes you not die is oftentimes my
least favorite ending because the
character I didn't even know who the
hell I was I don't care if he lives or
dies
he wasn't just an extension to me in a
body they might have all been a copper
bronze statue or something oh I wanted
so much more but I guess that's a good
thing a game it was scary and it made me
want more I guess just suck
somewhat disappointing ending
so anyway I'll wrap it up here instead
of my inane rambling I do not make games
so I cannot judge those that do they
made this incredibly well it was worthy
as the $10 I paid but that's just my
opinion
so either way thank you all so much for
watching click out the other Let's Plays
I've done there's a ton of them down
description blah but a whole bunch of
them that you can enjoy and keep
watching so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
I got a circle back at the water tower
and then I'll have only one location to
go and I know
you stay back you [ __ ] don't you know
who I am it my markiplier